Này 10 năm tâm tâm người, một sĩ dựa đã có đoàn công tác kìm chà bốn dự án nhà ở xa hội,
đông thời làm việc với ui bán nhân dân thành phố Hanoi, về tiến độ hoàn thành năm 2020,
và kế hoạch chỉ tiêu năm 2020, thứ trường xây dựa mỗi văn sinh, đen nghị thành phố Hanoi, cho thành chà,
kìm chà giá nhà ở xa hội, bởi giá đang có hiện tự ở mất cao kỳ lục.
Tựa của Hanoi 2020 đến nay, liên tiếp dự án nhà xa hội tại Thủ Đô, được hợi công, nhưng giá có suy hướng tăng.
Bà năm trước, giá mở bán loại nhà này dưới hai mi trộ đồng một mệt vong, đến nay liên tục sách hiện nơi bán hai mệt làm đến hai mi chính phẩy bốn trộ đồng.
Mất cao nhất hiện này, thuộc về khu nhà ở xa hội thường thành, tên thương mại rài Ct lòng châu,
với giá mở bán hai mi chính phẩy bốn trộ đồng một mệt vong, gồm về A T, chưa có kinh vĩ bảo chi.
Mười mua phải chi chính trọng bốn mi trộ đến hai thị đồng, tuy giận tích để xửa tại đây.
Theo để án phát triển ít, một trộ căn nhà xa hội, Hanoi được xa làm năm 2019, đến hết năm 2020,
dừng năm nay, tuy 녹 kinh hoàn thành bốn miền sáo trăm mởi bianh.